speak now to Wayne Jones the landlord of
the turf Pub right next to wrexham
Stadium in a well-known face from the
documentary Wayne thank you very much
for coming on and first of all what a
day for your football club give us a
sense of the atmosphere there
Brilliance as you can see it's
absolutely packed you know an hour and a
half before the buses are set to go past
them it's uh yeah it's really starting
to build people really sample enjoy
themselves
I say football club Wayne but it's clear
from the documentary that this is about
the community this is about the place
and the people there how has this lifted
Spirits in wrexham
yeah absolutely listen we're only as
good as what happens on the football
field but these people behind me and all
around the town tonight will be always
having always will support this football
club it's the absolute Beating Heart of
the community and uh yeah nothing
surprising me with these people because
they're wonderful and they're very
supportive of the club and were they
suspicious at the beginning were you
suspicious at the beginning when Ryan
Reynolds and Rob came in and presumably
you didn't know what was going to happen
were there suspicions about you know the
documentary and everything
yeah I think there was purely because
we've had some you know some shady
owners in the past so yeah there was a
little bit of um skepticism but uh
listen whatever that whatever whatever
all the way within minutes and you know
two two years down the line we are you
know we're absolutely flying so um yeah
um no these guys are here for the long
term and uh like I said these fans
deserve it yeah it looks like your Pub
is also uh fly I mean just to put things
in perspective uh way I mean 15 years
ago the the club pretty much well it was
pretty much finished dropping out of the
league all together can you and the
supporters behind you there and the rest
of the town can you believe what's
happened
absolutely not no obviously we've you
know I've said it several times before
we've hit the jackpot we've had some you
know really tricky times everybody that
supports this club knows that um but one
thing for sure is that they've always
stuck by it you know they've give Deeds
to the houses their savings and
everything so we're not with you know
we're light years away from where we
were even three years ago so
um no we can't quite believe it but uh
it's one hell of a ride and one hell of
a ride I hope continues so what is the
plan now I mean you obviously League two
you can get from League two to the
Premier League other clubs have done it
it has been done I think I think your
Rivals Swansea uh did it but what are
your expectations
listen the hardest part for me was going
up the national league we've managed to
achieve that so um you know the worlds
are at our feet Now isn't it you know
we've got brilliant owners brilliant
supporters wonderful fan base and uh
sponsors tripping over themselves to
plant money into the club so uh with us
back and behind me and this you know
back into these owners um people laugh
when they say can we reach the Premier
League but they won't be laughing in a
year or two when we're shooting up them
leagues that's for sure so
um yeah listen as a football supporter
and a fan you got a dream you want to be
at the top right otherwise why do it so
the owners believe we can do it the fans
believe we can do it and I believe we
can do it yeah the directions just said
in my Champions League that might be
doing things I mean that might be a step
too fast I'm looking fine look I'm look
I'm looking for I'm looking I'm looking
forward to the day we're turning You by
munix over and things like that listen
you're joking obviously we're light
years away from that but uh you know we
have to dream don't we you know these
like I keep repeating myself these fans
deserve to be at the very top and that
one day we will be there yeah just
finally I mean do you worry what happens
when the cameras stop rolling thing that
you know the
all the fuss moves on if you get stuck
in League two for instance you know the
reality does bite sometimes
oh absolutely of course you know it's
it's all right joking about these things
there's going to come a time where we're
a little bit of a sticky pattern sure
nothing's ever going to go you know Rosy
all the time but
um yeah I mean listen a lot long before
the cameras came and long after the
cameras go this football club was still
repeating heartless Community regardless
whether this camera is all famous owners
in town that will always be the case all
right well listen Wayne uh enjoy the
night it'll be a very special one for
you and everyone there and we'll be back
with the pictures from the open top bus
parade but have a great night and thanks
very much for coming on